[Music]
foreign
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 180 no
question of the primeness of that number
I'm Dr Brett Weinstein you are Dr
Heather Hines I am um
do you know what today is
yes
uh work with me
do you know what today is no what's
today today is day 13
279. no it's being a dude really you did
the math I did do the math okay I think
I did it pretty carefully okay but
anyway I think that's kind of a big
accomplishment being a dude being a dude
okay yeah well congratulations sir thank
you I appreciate that yeah it's uh it's
quite something you know it's it's a
rush yeah uh if you're watching on
YouTube consider switching to rumble
that's where we are streaming as well
and that's where the chat is
um we are going to try to uh not do so
much at the top of the hour from from
now on and get into the heart of the
part of the show
um but I will say it is summer which uh
is the is much more Salient to me than
how many days Brett has been a dude and
um today we are going to be talking
about I mean I'm very very pleased with
your dudeness and all and that you've
never imagined that you could have
changed it but um you know I'm kind of
gotten used to it it doesn't change as
rapidly as the seasons you know yeah
yeah it's really not at all okay so So
today we're going to talk a little bit
about this conversation that you had
Brett with RFK Jr back in November 2021
in which we released in Dark Horse this
week talk a little bit about that uh
we're going to talk about adjuvants and
allergies and we're going to talk about
affirmative action and any other words
beginning in a that we might come up
with but those that's the plan for today
so we've got a lot we're not talking
about Alabaster despite what oh my God
it's going to be like that um okay so
we're going to return after today's
episode with a rumble exclusive q a as
we are going to be doing whenever we do
Q A's it's going to be on Rumble only so
please consider going to rumble now if
you're on YouTube joining there and of
course if you're just listening continue
just listening we've got new merch uh
Zach is going to show it it is uh it was
prompted by uh something that you said a
couple of live streams ago and uh it is
at darkhorsestore.org
psyop until proven otherwise there's the
artwork and it's on shirts it's on a
backpack I think it's on stickers and
it's on this handsome Gentleman on the
shirt so that's a little bit meta yes I
believe I was uh I was this artwork is
on all of the things
all right
um wow I'm gonna I'm gonna re-center
myself are you I am and uh how many days
have you been a dude there thirteen
thousand two hundred seventy nine if my
calculations are correct it is that
inclusive or exclusive
wow
it has a margin of error of five days oh
okay tempted to get the leap years
correctly calculated but I did not do a
careful job
so yeah it's possible that I'm off by a
couple days here or there and as you
point out we don't know whether we're
counting today
um and I mean you know I think in some
sense we shouldn't count today because
we don't know that I'm going to be a
dude for the full day until it's over
yes we do
well actually not I was thinking of um
you know death which can come at any
time for you I'm not expecting it but if
it did that would mean I hope it is many
many decades in the future but at that
point you'll be a dead dude
interesting point this brings up my my
point about the mind brain distinction
which we will save for another day I
mean maybe like this is nothing that
we're going to be talking about today or
we won't go in Sex and gender at all but
uh dude yes is a description of sex
not just that at least the way I've
calculated it
um dude it's a description of sex thus
having nothing to do with mind it's it's
well no no
um so the way I calculated it
dude is something that happens
on your 18th birthday wait what the
definition of dude which so I didn't I
didn't think about the number you
produced at all that was starting at 18.
sort of expecting you to calculate yeah
of course
um and what was your number 13 279
um but dude for the purposes of my
calculation was defined as adult human
male b or otherwise
wait what adult human male be or
otherwise
what does that mean male or female
either one
because that's how we use it in our
house because we grew up in California
and we know how to properly use this
term
how many days do you think you've been a
dude 13 279 I'm gonna be embarrassed if
I'm way off but
um
yeah I mean not all of them were good
most of them were but you know it varies
that's the thing about life as a dude
and uh
yeah yeah it's about right yeah
I'm in the name thank goodness so dude
is man which is again uh reflective of
you know adult human male males about
your sex not your gender yeah but we use
the term interchangeably in our
household it's not it's not a sex-based
term but then you CA you're gonna have a
bit of dude since you were 18 then you
were a dude before that I don't think so
I think it's kind of like you would
refer to a child as sir but you don't
really mean it we've got a 17 year old
son yes you you've called him dude
totally but it's it's a you know I first
of all I know he's headed this direction
and second of all it's sort of a it's an
honorific here I was trying to clear the
decks get rid of all of the other stuff
at the top of the hour but no
oh here we are in the audience yeah
um okay uh so we have sponsors uh for
whom we are for whom for which for that
we are very grateful uh all of whom have
products or services that we actually
and truly vouch for we always start
these live streams with three right at
the top of the hour here we go
and they are biome American Hartford
gold and Seed our first sponsor this
week is bio maker of knobs nobs knobs is
a new kind of dentifrus Dental first is
a word that I learned upon looking into
knobs actually I learned it from you you
learned it for beat it I mean I'd heard
it before but I figured it was just a
fancy word for toothpaste but no
dentifers is anything you use to clean
your teeth it could be toothpaste but
also powders or in fact knobs knobs are
fantastic we started using this product
several months ago and approached them a
bit being a sponsor rather than the
other way around biome that's biom biome
without an e on the end makes a
fantastic product that all four of us
Brett and me and Zach our producer and
Toby aforementioned 17 year old now use
it daily now we can attest that uh
there's a word missing here and I wrote
this we can attest that they are telling
the truth when they say that they are
brand focused on transparency safety and
efficacy I think I was just like getting
rid of pronouns and I yeah you went a
bit too far it's way too far
um seriously biome says they're brand
focused on transparency safety and
efficacy and we're convinced let's talk
fluoride for a moment fluoride is the
anti-cavity ingredient in most
toothpastes that you already know about
but as we discussed in our book
hunter-gatherer's guide the 21st century
the fluoride and drinking water and
toothpaste is not in a molecular form
that is found in nature or that has ever
been part of our diet and Evermore
research is pointing to neurotoxicity
from fluoride exposure especially in
children knobs from biome doesn't
contain fluoride but that in and of
itself doesn't make it unique many oral
care products are now abandoned in
fluoride as the research continues to
emerge about its toxicity but unlike
comparative products knobs includes a
different and far better remineralizing
agent and that is hydroxyapatite
hydroxyapatite is the main component of
the enamel in your teeth and is in your
bones as well it has been extensively
studied in medicine and dentistry and is
as effective as fluoride and
remineralizing too tooth or teeth
without the toxicity of fluoride
hydroxyapatite doesn't really stop
cavities from forming it can even at
rest tooth decay once it's underway
uh and I have a I have a reference on
that if you're interested
excellent I love ads with references I
like I like putting primary primary
scientific literature into our ads I
went through a poem with a reference but
that's a story for a different day yeah
yeah yeah yeah and I remember this I
think yeah
um so hydroxyapatite can actually arrest
tooth decay once it's underway uh it is
a great remineralizing re-mineralizing
agent with no known toxicity unlike
fluoride and that is what is in knobs
furthermore even most natural
toothpastes that are free of fluoride
still have lots of abrasive ingredients
like charcoal baking soda and eggshells
knobs has none of these things knobs
also has no sulfates no parabens no
phthalates or microplastics no BS and
OBS it's right there in the name
furthermore knobs comes in the form of
dehydrated tablets which allows them to
be shelf stable without any
preservatives take a tablet chew it a
few times and brush as normal your teeth
are going to feel fantastically clean
because they are also unlike with
toothpaste TSA has no interest in knobs
because they're tablets so if you're
flying with knobs you don't risk losing
your dentifrus insecurity
so check out knobs at
www.betterbiome.com Darkhorse that's
again biome without the e that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-b-i-o-m I'm going to say
that again
b-e-t-t-e-r-b-i-o-m.com Darkhorse
listeners can enjoy 15 off their first
one month supply of knobs from now until
July 17 2023.
all right our second sponsor this week
is American Heart for gold if you listen
to Dark Horse regularly you already know
just how incompetent and unstable many
of our institutions are becoming
inflation probably even if you don't
listen to Dark Horse regularly you know
that because how could you not inflation
is at its highest level in 40 years
interest rates are Sky High we are cop
between runaway inflation and a
recession and our leaders are
increasingly nonsensical all of this
threatens businesses jobs and retirement
funds finding ways to secure your nest
egg and insulate your wealth is more
important than ever and adding precious
metals to your assets is a great way to
stabilize your Investments and protect
yourself financially American Hartford
gold is a precious metals dealer that
can help you do just that American
Hartford gold helps individuals and
families predict their wealth by
diversifying with precious metals they
make it simple and easy to protect your
savings and retirement accounts with
physical gold and silver with one short
phone call they can have physical gold
and silver delivered right to your door
or inside your IRA or 401k
they are the highest rated firm in the
country with an A plus rating from the
Better Business Bureau and thousands of
satisfied clients if you call them right
now
they will give you up to five thousand
dollars of free silver on your first
qualifying order contact them today by
visiting the link in the episode
description or call
866-828-1117 that's
866-828-1117 or text Darkhorse to 998899
once more that's
all right our final sponsor this week is
seed a probiotic that really works your
gut and your immune system work together
coordinating your body's response to the
world both around and within you seed
helps improve the health of your gut
microbiome which means that it supports
you becoming healthier overall our
resident gut microbiome directly impacts
the development and function of the
immune system even before we're born
microbes inform your immune system
teaching our body how to distinguish
benign substances and pathogenic
antigens that is substances that our
body doesn't recognize as its own you
can support your gut immune access the
Axis of Awesome in a variety of ways
including by prioritizing sleep your
body operates on a 24-hour cycle your
circadian rhythm new research suggests
that the gut microbiome has its own
circadian clock and that changes to your
normal rhythms and that changes to your
normal rhythms can disrupt your microbes
and important functions that they
perform prioritizing regular
insufficient sleep can help us keep our
gut immune access healthy
you can also support your gut immune
axis by taking seeds ds01 daily
symbiotic seed is a plant-based
Prebiotic and probiotic with 24 strains
that have been clinically or
scientifically studied for their
benefits 16 of those 24 strains are
specifically geared towards Digestive
Health as you would expect from a
probiotic and four of the 24 probiotic
strains are known to promote healthy
skin your skin like your gut has its own
microbiome seed supports supports both
gut and skin health
seed is free from 14 major classes of
antigens including but not limited to
sugar animal products soy gluten peanut
glyphosate Dairy shellfish and corn and
seed is basically double hulled with its
capsule in capsule design it is
engineered to maintain viability through
your digestive tract until it reeks your
colon where you want it and the same
design makes it resistant to oxygen
moisture heat and heat meaning that no
Refrigeration is necessary seeds daily
symbiotic support
reading is not going so well for me
today but I'm I'm getting there doing
great man
thank you welcome
um access of Awesome
the Axis of Awesome okay yes uh seeds
daily symbiotics supports guts and skin
and heart health and micronutrient
synthesis we have heard from several
people who have used seed and Report
improvements to their digestive function
in 24 to 48 hours so start a new healthy
habit today visit seed.com Darkhorse and
use the code Darkhorse to receive to
redeem 25 off your first month of seeds
ds01 daily symbiotic that's seed.com
Darkhorse and use the code darkhorset
checkup
[Music]
our Axis of Awesome Axis of Awesome
again that's biome American Hartford
gold and Seed
for whom we are grateful all of them and
also grateful
to Robert F Kennedy Jr absolutely for
the conversation uh that you had with
him back in November 2021 and for many
other things besides indeed so I wanted
to talk a little bit about the
conversation that I had with Bobby
Kennedy Jr in November and in particular
why it was that we didn't release it
until now now I will say I was never
planning to keep this Secret in fact I
made a little video uh that explained
some of my reasoning that I placed on my
Twitter subscriber feed so subscribers
could see it and Twitter behaved very
oddly with respect to this post is it
not subscribers thought but it was
invisible to people who did not
subscribe which is not the way Twitter
is supposed to function I have no idea
what that was about it's still up people
if you want to subscribe you can see it
um I may at some point show it to the
public just so you can see I wasn't
pretending or anything like that but
what interested me was that there was a
lot of discussion
about nefarious motives that would have
caused us to release this now why now
why not in November 2021 and uh
nefarious okay
well I don't know people alleged that we
had been paid by somebody that we had
coordinated with the Kennedy campaign
none of this is true
um so anyway I thought I would just
clear up the mystery so right not true
but also if if we had which we didn't
coordinate with the Kennedy campaign how
would that be nefarious
well you can imagine
one can apparently imagine people can
hurl crap at you all you want they can
and I mean look I think this is a useful
lesson because in this particular case
you the audience can't really know any
more than you can know anywhere else but
you and I are in a perfect position to
know for certain exactly why we did what
we did and that none of the things that
are being hypothesized are true
um but the idea that people are so
primed to see nefarious motives that
anything that is in any way out of the
ordinary or seems to help somebody that
they don't like is instantly triggering
of uh hypotheses so
first of all let's clear up what
happened
uh Bobby Kennedy came to our house you
can see in this uh podcast it is our old
studio uh in the uh the sauna
that we used to have in Portland
um and we had what I thought was a
fantastic conversation the problem is
if I can just recap the history here for
people who maybe haven't followed us for
very long
you and I once upon a time were
professors of biology and our
careers as professors at a state school
which you would think is a very safe
career came to a spectacular end when
the college went into full meltdown uh
at least in part surrounding our
opposition to
um policy proposals that were being
Advanced to the college that it was our
obligation to object to because they
weren't good policy proposals so that
was the first time our income evaporated
yeah the second time that happened when
after covid began and you and I started
unpacking the biological details of
covid we inevitably ran up against the
Preposterous features of the narrative
that we were all being given about
um repurposed drugs about uh the origin
of the virus about vaccine safety and
Effectiveness and
um as that was well more than a year
after code began well more than a year
after we do we'd been doing these live
streams
um that you know our income was once
again evaporated evaporated by YouTube
demonetizing us yeah and I've forgotten
exactly where it happened but either
after the Corey podcast or the Malone
Kirsch podcast
um
demonetized our Channel and it has never
been remonetized so the bulk of our
income came through YouTube and YouTube
killed it within an hour they they
demonetized both of our channels and
they never uh they never fixed that even
though they were obviously wrong about
these issues
okay so having had
Bobby Kennedy Jr to our house and had a
very good discussion In the Heat of the
pandemic at the point when a tremendous
amount of Firepower was directed at us
over our uh dissident stance on various
issues of covid
uh I and we thought it was too risky to
release that podcast and so we didn't
now
it wasn't strictly about YouTube there
was lots of stuff pointed at us across
many domains we don't know the nature of
it all we can tell is that a huge amount
of money was spent to slander and uh to
slander us and others and to prevent
audience from ever finding us so in the
midst of that environment we made a
decision that it just wasn't safe to
release this podcast
so
the Wii is you and Bobby is that is that
the way you're talking about
collectively we uh in it was not Bobby
Bobby would have been okay with
releasing it because yet in large
measure already paid the price of his
stances in public so
um he was ready to go but
we those of us involved in Dark Horse
which is a tiny number just decided not
to release it
the
um
other question is why now
right and the answer to why now is
to be honest I had forgotten wasn't that
I didn't know that we had recorded the
podcast but as I was watching other
discussions with Bobby Kennedy it
occurred to me hey actually we have a
discussion with Bobby Kennedy and it
covered lots of stuff in a way that I
thought was
frankly not done elsewhere and so it
just seemed like time to release it was
it safe I don't know but uh it seemed
like a different environment than it
than it was in November of 2021. so
anyway that's why nobody paid us
no nefarious motives
yes it was somebody accused us or
demanded that we proved that it had
actually been recorded in November 2021
you can obviously tell that changes in
facial hair different Studio we don't
own that building anymore all of those
things so that's the long and short of
it
um
I did want to continue though and talk a
little bit about at least one of the
things in this podcast which I strongly
advise people to take a look at it's
really good and it also provides some
interesting insight into where our
mindset and Robert F Kennedy Junior's
mindset was in November 2021
um
it's also before his uh corrective
surgery for the wobble in his voice
which has changed his voice so anyway
this is a it's an interesting look into
a moment in the past not so long ago
when things were were different
um in the podcast actually pretty early
in the podcast we discuss an issue that
you and I have discussed on this podcast
many times since we may have discussed
it before then too I don't remember but
the issue is one of the particular
Technologies involved in the
construction of modern vaccines
and the the one that
Bobby lays out a very good description
of why the vaccine landscape looks the
way it does at a technological level and
what he says is that traditional
vaccines involve attenuated versions of
a live virus
that that has a positive side the
positive side is it produces a very
robust immune response the negative side
is because you are using a live version
of a pathogen even though it's been
attenuated you can't control how it
evolves once you have injected it and in
fact there is substantial evidence that
a large fraction of the cases for
example of polio in the world today are
actually Downstream vaccine induced our
vaccine-induced polio
so that's a terrible story right you
don't want to inject something that gets
away from you by evolutionary uh
selection
the alternative has been to use inert
either dead viruses or pieces of dead
viruses and the problem with that it
solves The evolutionary problem but it
creates a difference it solves that
particular evolutionary problem yes it
solves the problem of the pathogen
getting away from you because you're not
injecting a pathogen you're injecting
something that can't evolve because it
doesn't reproduce
the problem with the fragments or dead
viruses is that because you are not
actually stick with anything the immune
system does not react uh in a
significant way it treats it as a
mundane garbage collection problem
rather than an infectious agent and so
it does not develop a robust immunity it
creates a very weak vaccine
and so what was discovered was that
irritating the immune system with an
adjuvant
causes the immune system to wake up and
react and so you can get a robust immune
response to the antigens in the vaccine
without running the risk of uh selection
taking your pathogen and making it
increased safety in the domain of
reduced pathogenicity of the antigen
that is being injected right now I must
say I did not have a deep relationship
with the idea of adjuvants prior to
covet and all of the investigation
surrounding vaccines that resulted
in the aftermath of that I feel
that the story of vaccines as we find
them today in the market
is a very revealing story it is a story
that illuminates many of the problems
that we have in academic science it
illuminates the problems that we have in
governmental policy and
let's just put it this way
in the podcast I actually say that I
love
vaccines and that my skepticism of the
covet vaccines has me alarmed because
this is a technology that I have
actually lectured on
um as a huge benefit to society and not
the covet vaccine it's not mRNA vaccines
but traditional vaccines traditional
vaccines
um I wouldn't say that today I would say
it very differently as I I'm sure you
would I would say the underlying
fundamental technology at the heart of a
vaccine alerting the immune system to a
pathogen that it has yet to encounter so
that it is well prepared when it does
encounter it that is a beautiful elegant
mechanism priming the immune system
priming the immune system with
information could hardly be more elegant
however
the hazards involved in either creating
a pathogen that can evolve or needing to
use adjuvants to trigger a robust
response or in the case of covid some
third technology where we hijack your
cells and turn them into vaccine
factories none of these things racial
vaccine factories yeah none of these
things are or no not vaccine factories
partial virus factories yeah we
basically use a pseudovirus that hijacks
cells which then results in those cells
being targeted none of these things are
sense are safe in principle right they
all carry significant dangers and in
fact I learned from a more recent
discussion uh by RFK Jr that the origin
of pharmaceutical legal immunity
surrounding vaccines was based on the
argument that the production of vaccines
that vaccines were inherently unsafe and
therefore if the government wanted
pharmaceutical companies to produce them
that it needed to immunize them from
legal liability right
and much architecture is Downstream of
that but nonetheless these are the most
some of the most robust immunity we have
it is yeah
no breakthroughs but uh
um no breakthrough cases oh it's almost
too good yeah
um but so anyway what I wanted to say is
I think many of us are now rethinking
what we understood about vaccines you
and I wrote into our book that these
were one of the three great medical
triumphs of human history and let me
just say
um you know we I I talked a bit about uh
last week on Dark Horse
about the failure of any of the vaccines
in the current uh childhood vaccination
schedule as recommend is produced and
enforced
I don't know about enforced as produced
and recommended by the CDC none of them
have been tested against Placebo and I
ran through a couple of examples and
then I wrote about that somewhere also
in my sub stack this week that's um you
know specifically the issue and and in
that I walked through some of
some of you know my personal history and
it's also yours with regard to our
approach to vaccines like how you know
how enthusiastic we have been and and
precisely as you just said how
how enthusiastic I remain and I hear you
remain about uh the the core the core
idea the the central idea and you know
while recognizing that inherently either
you know put aside the MRNA the the new
third version for the moment um but
either of these um you know the
traditional uh the uh attenuated yeah
attenuated
um vaccines have the risk of um you know
the virus or other pathogen evolving in
you into you know and and making you
sick with the disease itself uh or the
the dead or partial virus or other
pathogen requiring adjuvants in order to
trigger your immune system enough uh you
know there are risks in both cases
neither neither of them are inherently
safe
um but I
continue to believe that at least in
that first category that original
category of vaccine that there are
vaccines that have done far more good
than harm
um I guess you know
one doesn't know how to engage in the
proper level of skepticism when you
discover that you've been hoodwinked
over and over over and over again yes so
what I would say is
here's what isn't safe and effective
for-profit Pharma being in charge of the
production of these things and then the
testing of them that's right that's
clearly not safe yeah
um in fact it's lethal
as for whether or not vaccines can be uh
can have a risk reward ratio that makes
them favorable I still believe that they
can but what I am certain of is
that we need to set a high bar for the
establishment that a vaccine is worth
the risks that come with it right we
need a robust Academy that can test that
question and we need uh
governmental Regulators that
um
prevent the release of you know a
vaccine that seems to have a marginal
benefit isn't worth it because the risks
that come along with it that may be hard
to detect are aren't worth it so I would
like to see this technology leveraged
well
for Humanity on the basis of net benefit
that is well established in careful
tests that are not corrupted yes
all of that said the reinvestigation
of vaccines how they are produced and my
own history with them has me in the
following predicament I a professor who
have literally lectured on this
technology and told my students how
marvelous It is believed that I was in
some sense misled in a way that I often
talk about with respect to other topics
right where you come to believe the
diagram in the textbook right the
diagram in the textbook that describes
how vaccines are produced and work is
not to talk about adjuvants typically
right it talks about the underlying
technology which is elegant if you had
told me
that there were ingredients in the
vaccines whose purpose was to to annoy
the immune system to to agitate it I
would have said well
how much downside is there to doing that
right now
in the podcast that we just released in
November 2021 podcast from the vault
uh Bobby Kennedy reveals that he his
spasmodic dystonia the the uh yeah I
think it's dystonia
um
the wobble in his voice he did not know
he had no reason to think that it was
the result of uh a vaccine injury until
as a lawyer who was working on the
question he ended up reading I think the
insert of a flu vaccine which
specifically named the condition he had
as a known side effect so that was very
late it did this did not trigger his
interest in it but nonetheless he came
to think that quite possibly he was
suffering from a vaccine injury himself
now I also wonder if several pathologies
that I have might be the result of this
in particular
allergies which have
um had a pretty significant impact on my
life the three that are most important
are long time listeners will know I have
a severe wheat allergy triggered by even
the tiniest contact with wheat a little
wheat in a soy sauce that somebody
includes and doesn't think about weed
because it says on the bottle it's made
of soy that's enough to trigger me right
why do I have a wheat allergy my
ancestors have been eating meat for
thousands of years
um I also have a pretty debilitating
allergy to Grass pollen on days when the
grass is flowering uh I you know I just
become a drippy mess become so sad yeah
not not obvious why sorry that would be
just like tears float like it looks like
sadness but it's not it's not good yeah
but and then there is the fact and which
I've talked about years ago on the
podcast that I have an allergy to
marijuana right it's an allergy that
until
my current thinking on vaccines I
credited to uh overuse of marijuana
but I now wonder if what's going on in
all of these cases
is that you are injected with a vaccine
that is based on antigens rather than
living pathogens
it comes with an adjuvant that adjuvant
wakes up your immune system and it
starts reacting to molecules that it
finds present in your system whether
that's things that are leaking out of
your gut and are exposed to your immune
system in the case of wheat whether it's
pollen that has entered your lungs
because you're breathing it in do you
happen to have gotten vaccinated during
grass flowering season right or if you
know you are using marijuana and you're
smoking it so just to put a little
interesting color on this here's the
thing about my marijuana allergy
and a my marijuana allergy in the end I
hesitate to say this because I can't
believe that it would actually be that
positive I don't think it is not
positive but it certainly did make it
easy to quit
um so you know here's the question if
um
if I
smoke pot
I react I get a ton of mucus uh in my
lungs
if I eat
I'm too old to have done Edibles I guess
or I quit before Edibles were a thing
but pot brownies were a thing if I eat a
pot brownie my lungs fill with mucus
which is interesting immunologically
right what it means is that the locus of
my allergy is in my lungs and even if
the antigen comes in from the back side
through the blood supply
it still triggers that mucosal uh
immunity in my lungs
so the question is did I get a shot
probably a flu shot in college and or
one of these uh one of these shots you
needed to travel to travel that's also
possible rabies or something or yeah I'd
have to go back and look the most likely
is flu shot because I got a lot of them
um which I now worry it was not such a
good idea they're not very effective
shots and the idea of re-vaccinating uh
in the same antigenic neighborhood again
and again is uh suspect to me now but
yeah I'm not sure that they were um so
so common then
what flu shots
I got them in the early 90s
um
in any case the
the over the overarching point here is
we have an epidemic of allergies right
now I've heard some rather compelling
explanations we talk about you know the
hygiene hypothesis we talk about the
absence of uh parasitic worms that we
have the ige system that's the IG
immunoglobulin uh
uh e is particularly associated with
allergies that that system is not busy
because we don't have worms and it can
be caused to react to things that are
not actually pathogens but the question
is
given the number of allergies
is one of the important factors the
environmental context following an
injection with an adjuvented vaccine is
that why I have an allergy to wheat is
that why I have an allergy to grass is
that why I have an allergy to marijuana
and oh go ahead no I mean the the
prediction of course is that you would
not see an uptick in allergies following
uh vaccination with live live attenuated
vaccines if if they also do not have
adjuvants and why would they need them
right so that vaccines without adjuvants
uh are at least far far less likely to
produce other kinds of of immune
responses developing although you know
it's possible there would be some
because you are triggering the immune
system to respond to some degree but the
adjuvants produce a sort of a
generalized like oh my God what's going
on response in in the immune system that
uh the prediction is will then have
broader more far-reaching effects with
regard specifically to things like
allergies asthma potentially other
health effects as well
absolutely
so that raises a question about how we
ought to be testing these things and
against what in other words you know the
net effect is really what we care about
right you do care about your immunity to
the pathogens in question but the
question is how much cost are you
willing to pay for that immunity for a
one-year immunity to
a flu that you will get it will suck and
you will get better right would you pay
with a lifetime of allergies of seasonal
allergies you know could you reduce the
effect of the seasonal allergies
um by immunizing at a moment that was
low allergen
could you you know have an air filter
that filtered a large fraction of the
air that you breathed in the two weeks
following a vaccination there are lots
of things that we could potentially do
well but also um dietary concerns right
so to to your point about
um is it possible that your gluten
allergy and that many other peoples rise
in dietary allergies is related to an
effectively inflamed immune system
following vaccination
that doesn't inherently mean that those
vaccines with their adjuvants are
something that should never be given to
anyone again that's a separate question
but at the very least it is quite
possible that a much reduced diet in the
wake of and I don't know if that means
two days two weeks hypoallergenic diet
uh in the you know two days two weeks I
don't know what the right time span
would be following vaccination
might then mean that you would develop
fewer food allergies to on the road once
you because once you've started once
you've resumed eating your normal diet
after your immune system had calmed the
[__] down yeah
um
I would also you know again there are
many things is there a protocol like
you're describing that would be helpful
there's also the question of what is the
threshold of benefit with respect to the
pathogen in question that needs to be
reached to deal with an amorphous
concern about various environmental
sensitivities that you might develop but
I would point out yes those are not just
quality of life concerns which are not
minor right obviously the pathology that
I suffered before discovering that I had
a wheat allergy and the pathology that I
Still Still suffer when I end up eating
wheat without knowing that it's there
right that is a significant uh
degradation and quality of life
absolutely um
but the uh
this is also a question of life and
death right lots of people we know
people who have died from asthma right
which is an allergic response in most
people so you know we're talking about
it's serious degradation in quality of
life and the loss of many lives to an
undescribed
pathology that may well be and I would
point out
once you know that the technology
involved in vaccines involves
inflaming the immune system to get a
more robust response it is an absolutely
obvious hypothesis that some fraction of
the overactivity of the immune system is
the result of that very same technology
absolutely and this is a this is a
different point but related and critical
which is that much as when adults decide
to travel someplace where for instance
yellow fever is endemic and either have
a choice to make
or the choice is actually you can't go
there if you don't get this vaccine it
is a different kind of choice to make
uh
they we
end up
carefully assessing all the parts which
is how bad is the disease
what are my chances of exposure to it
what are the chances of if I'm exposed I
will get it if I am exposed and I get it
what are the chance is there Treatment
available will I have access to the
treatment if I you know what's what's
the CFR like what you know what what are
how bad is the disease and what are my
chances of getting a bad case of it
we do that as adults when we make
decisions about for instance the
vaccinations that we get when we travel
especially to Tropical regions as you
and I have spent a lot of our time
especially in our 20s doing
but as I was talking about last week the
proliferation of vaccines in the
childhood vaccination schedule from a
handful when we were children getting
vaccinated to an incredible number now
has never so far as I
remember from when our own children were
young nor have I ever you know heard in
mainstream circles been accompanied by a
discussion of oh okay the CDC is
recommending a new vaccine for disease X
let us tell you about disease X let us
tell you
how it manifests how common it is
whether or not there's treatment aside
from the vaccine you know whether or not
your child is actually at risk of being
exposed to it
and all of those are actually highly
relevant to a question of whether or not
this is the right thing to do for the
health of a person with regard you know
it's not just
this disease is something that we have a
vaccine for therefore you get it if you
live in Los Angeles and you are never
leaving Los Angeles no one is suggesting
to you that you get a yellow fever
vaccine yep no one okay if you live if
you were born if you live in Los Angeles
no one is and you are 30 no one is
suggesting to you that you go get a new
uh polio vaccine or smallpox vaccine
right we we understand this and yet we
are we have labeled we are vilified we
are you know we are labels antibacters
we are vilified for saying
it's not sufficient
that you the company with the financial
interest and making sure that as many
people as possible take this thing
assure me that your product is good
against a disease that I don't know
anything about
now maybe it's your responsibility to
educate me and then I'm going to go try
to find a second opinion as to what that
disease is and what my actual risk
factors are but I'd also like to know
why we aren't
simultaneously focused as much or more
on
treatment for the very very rare things
you know we hear a lot about you know
prevention is better than than treatment
and in the abstract I think that's true
but if we're talking about especially if
we're talking about children
at very low risk from things that don't
actually circulate in children okay what
if what if somehow your child
um did come down with hepatitis B what
is there to be done about it like how
did how did that child come down with
hepatitis B in the first place but like
what what would the treatment be and
might for those conditions that a child
is very very unlikely to get exposed to
uh wouldn't treatment wouldn't knowing
that there is treatment out there be at
least an approach that we could talk
about as an alternative to uh to the
rapid proliferation of non Placebo
tested
vaccines on the childhood vaccination
schedule
the problem what you have said is
perfectly reasonable it's effectively
unassailable because all you're asking
for is the obvious evidence that the
thing is worthwhile in the context of
the thing to which it's targeted right
right the problem here
I'm increasingly aware
is that for some reason without any
discussion that I am aware of
vaccines have become
sacred yep right these are things about
and and you know who did this and all
you have to do to make it into a vaccine
apparently is to say
that's a vaccine that's a vaccine it is
blessed yes Abracadabra you're a vaccine
and that's what happened with coven that
and that is what happened with the MRNA
shots which are not vaccines right right
was that they were blessed as vaccines
and having been blessed it was
impossible to raise the obvious
questions which is what got you and me
in so much trouble right what you and I
I will remind people of the history what
we said when these things were announced
at the point that we still thought these
might be very useful they might be the
way that we actually uh got back to
normal life after covid right we figured
we would we would delay as long as we
would delay because that was reasonable
we would delay in the same way that we
delayed our children's vaccinations when
they were kids vaccinations we knew they
would get but we delayed them so that
their development would be as complete
as possible at the point that they got
them
but what you and I said
that ran us a foul of the power
structure that put us in the Jeopardy
that caused us not to release the RFK
podcast back in November of 2021 what we
said was
these vaccines may very well be
effective but when they tell us that
they are safe
they cannot possibly know that right now
that is the mildest criticism you could
possibly level right we didn't say that
they were harmful we said they don't
know that they're safe because they
haven't been around long enough for them
to know long-term what happens if you
take one and that means they are unsafe
right it doesn't mean they're harmful
but it means in the same way that
driving drunk May Do no harm but it
isn't safe these vaccines are not safe
and the point is for that minimal
obvious nearly tautological criticism
you and I were cast out as Heretics
right right so here's my point
we have discovered that there is
something sacred inside of our Medical
establishment our scientific
establishment right not even it's it's
culture-wide well that's true but the
point is it is emanating from the high
Church of Science and the New York Times
right and the point is we know who the
bad people are they are the ones who
will criticize our sacred thing right
now how did that happen let's give them
the benefit of the doubt
the benefit of the doubt is that Public
Health
erected for itself
a right to lie
and the reason that a direct a right to
lie if we give it the benefit of the
doubt is that in order to avoid a
collective action problem where people
get the benefit of other people's being
vaccinated without taking their tiny
share of the risk that we needed to tell
them things were safe that we're not
perfectly safe right and that was a
[__] and B A violation of Nuremberg
in and of itself yes right public health
is not allowed to lie to us about
treatments that we are taking because we
have a right to informed consent that as
you and I pointed out several weeks ago
uh was sufficient that implied right to
inform consent before it was ever
codified was sufficient to cause the
Nuremberg courts to hang seven doctors
right
so Public Health never had a right to
lie to us but it did somehow insert into
the culture the right to
um
Place vaccines outside the realm of
criticism to declare anyone who violates
that boundary whether they are
scientifically qualified or not to
declare them Heretics and to punish them
publicly right to cast them out and that
is
um
a remarkable story especially in light
of the fact that a huge fraction of the
people who are
um doing the demonizing doing the work
of this vaccine Church
believe themselves to be
um
faithless
and purely scientific right right and
this is not how science works and we can
now see you know I I am proud to say
that you and I played an important role
in Breaking the public health narrative
which was never true and now a large
number of people are awake to this
completely unscientific protection that
these Technologies enjoy frankly in the
market right this is a this is a money
changers moment this is a moment when
the money changers you know somebody's
coming in to flip card tables uh in the
in the temple because the money changers
have taken over what is supposed to be
beyond that corruption yeah
um
well true all true and
you know I increasingly keep coming back
to and thinking about a number of issues
including affirmative action which is
where we're gonna spend some time now um
soon
but
um the people who think of themselves as
on the left are more likely to be
thinking at sort of the population level
the collective good level and the people
who think of themselves on the right are
more likely to be thinking about
individual level Rights and Freedoms
and I think that's true to some extent
and I can see actually shades of that
and having read several of the opinions
from this Supreme Court decision that
got handed down a couple days ago
uh but
it's also fascinating because and I've
said this before on Dark Horse
um
long time ago when I was teaching uh
with a uh an entomologist at Evergreen
we were teaching uh we're going to be
teaching a first year program together
that is freshmen you know brand new fall
quarter you know a lot of kids straight
out of straight out of high school
although we had a lot of a lot of kids a
lot of students at Evergreen that
weren't straight out of high school but
um you know Russian college students and
um we were teaching statistics as part
of the program and one of the things
that I asked him my excellent colleague
you know what is it that you really
really want these students to walk away
with after 10 weeks with us
he said I want them to understand how to
think about populations
and that was part of why we did
statistics as part of a freshman program
that was a lot of field work and you
know most most freshmen did not want
statistics as part of that
and uh
and I that has stuck with me
um that that line has stuck with me that
um and it then became clear because I
then started teaching statistics
associated with my animal behavior
program and and mostly animal behavior
and it was remarkable I'm not talking
about like you know statistical thinking
or you know understanding whatever
software it was that we were using that
year or how to make compelling Graphics
that accurately relate what it is that
you have found uh with with the numbers
but just like thinking at the level of
populations versus individuals is
actually very very challenging for
people
and yet
the the
people who think of themselves on the
left mostly imagine that they are doing
things that are good for the population
and they're really not and I think this
may come down to I know I haven't quite
figured out where the disconnect is but
it feels like a they've often got groups
to find that aren't real groups
and B they don't understand enough about
Game Theory to understand that whatever
you know solution they put in place
isn't simply going to be gamed by the
people who will game any system and
they'll make off like Bandits and leave
everyone else
um you know deserving and not out of
luck uh but there's there's there's
something very strange about a system in
which uh people are simultaneously
basically arguing for
um population level Solutions
who can't actually understand what it
means to be in a population or to be
acting as a member of a population well
I don't I don't know how strange it is
um it goes back to an argument that
we've we've deployed here before
um we talked about uh awkwardly enough
team loser
um and the
um
never-ending appetite for communism and
the argument
that I would put forward is this and
let's let's be fair
civilization does not work very well at
the moment it leaves a large number of
people bereft of useful skills yet
injures you know use lead in your water
and leaves people dumber than they would
otherwise be all sorts of things it
betrays people but it leaves a lot of
people in a position where faced with
the rigors of the market they don't have
useful skills to deploy so they you know
at best they can sort of be a cog in
this machine and uh it's not a very
appealing uh way to live
the and don't we need to help and
protect those people of course we need
to fix civilizations so it stops hurting
people I mean that's like that's that's
that's
one of the like Prime directives of of
team of Team blue largely right like
supposed to be but what has happened is
team blue has become
uh a corrupt entity that
parasitizes that instinct and it
attracts now a coalition of people who
aren't really
these aren't people who have been burned
and are honestly looking for a you know
a decent way to live these are people
who uh
upon recognizing that they don't have uh
skills to deploy in the market
uh are interested in tearing stuff down
stealing from other people right it's
become a coalition and
the overarching point is that this is
perpetually a source of new inventions
of Communism the reason that communism
every time it's tried it doesn't work
that excuses then deployed it's never
really been tried and it will be tried
again and it won't work why are we
seeing Marxist views suddenly showing up
in team blue
um when we know very well that they
don't work the answer is if you divide
the world into people who have an above
average capacity to make their way in
the world as it's found and people who
have a below average capacity to make
their way in the world as it's found you
have a ready-made Coalition amongst
people who will be on the losing end to
uh use the system to extract resources
from others so it's like it's
traditional suddenly there's no there's
no suddenly there's uh
there's group level solutions from from
the left that's that's that's always
been part of the but they're my point is
there are honorable group level
uh instincts that did live over on the
left what we are seeing now is not
honorable it's cynical from the point of
view of the elites and it is petty and
destructive and not interested in our
Collective well-being elsewhere it's
interested in using that excuse for
theft and
um you know an honorable Progressive
Movement would be a very valuable thing
but it it essentially doesn't exist and
um this other thing is sucking up all
the oxygen in the room that would result
in it uh emerging
can we can we move forward let's do it
all right uh so
I
could spend weeks clearly uh delving
into uh weeks months years of career uh
delving into the question of affirmative
action and the legal precedence in the
U.S and presumably elsewhere as well
um but I did spend a bit of time in the
last couple days following uh the
Supreme Court decision that was handed
down on June 29th two days ago as we're
speaking uh into simultaneous cases this
was students for fair admissions
Incorporated versus president and
fellows of Harvard College and students
prefer admissions versus University of
North Carolina at all
so the majority opinion was written by
Justice Roberts and begins in these
cases we consider whether the admission
systems used by Harvard College and the
University of North Carolina
two of the oldest institutions of Higher
Learning in the United States are lawful
under the equal protection Clause of the
14th Amendment
there will be no spoilers here when I
say the majority opinion which was six
three was that no they are not and I
will say that Justice Jackson recused
herself from the Harvard part of the
case because she herself had been in on
the board I can't remember exactly the
title but she she had been involved
enough in Harvard's
um governance uh that she did not feel
that she could dispassionately be part
of that case but
um there were interestingly
uh six opinions written
in this case there was the majority
opinion by Roberts which was joined by
the other five
uh the other five justices who were who
voted with him that was Roberts Thomas
Alito Gorsuch Kavanaugh and Barrett
um and then this is just in the order of
the 200 and something page document with
everything it's got a summary at the top
then you've got the Roberts majority
opinion then you've got Thomas
concurring in an opinion or such
concurring joined by Thomas Kavanaugh
concurring and then pseudomayor
dissenting as joined by Kagan and
Jackson and then Jackson dissenting even
though she had recused herself from the
Harvard Harvard part and so you know a
lot of voices and I will just so that
it's clear what I feel like I know and
what I don't know I read the summary the
so-called syllabus and I I read skimmed
both the Roberts majority opinion the
concurring opinion by Thomas and the
dissenting opinion by Sotomayor did not
look at Gorsuch Kavanaugh or Jackson
um
so
it's
fascinating and I will
maybe I will lead because I've said this
before although I'm not sure no actually
I'm gonna say for the end sort of where
I think
where I've been and where I am now on
affirmative action
um not having had my position changed
although having had it been much more
informed by by doing this bit of reading
let's just go a little bit of history
back both on
um the on a couple of a couple of prime
issues here
um this this history as borrowed from
the Roberts the majority opinion um by
Roberts again which came down two days
ago on June 29th the 14th Amendment
right in the wake of the Civil War the
14th Amendment uh Congress proposes and
ratifies it which specifies that quote
no State shall deny any person the equal
protection of the laws
um let me just have a little asterisk
here and suramayor's descent in her
dissenting opinion she points out that
simultaneous with the passing the 14th
Amendment Congress enacted a number of
race-conscious laws to fulfill the
amendment's promise of equality leaving
no doubt that the equal protection
Clause permits consideration of race to
achieve its goal so not the level of
um Bill of Rights
um of you know of amendments but
but there were simultaneous things that
happened at the same level at the same
time as the 14th Amendment
um and you know she of course she and
those who concur with her
um are using that to support the idea of
um race-based
um of using race as one of the factors
in applications that in this case
Harvard and UNC
uh later
um a few decades later Plessy versus
Ferguson uh in 1896 comes out with
separate but equal this is widely
understood I think universally
understood now to be to have been a
shameful decision yeah one of the worst
in the courts one of the worst in the
courts as at least the two
um at least Roberts and Thomas say this
in their you know these
it's not that anyone is supporting
Plessy V Ferguson right uh but that
stood the separate but equal stuff from
Plessy B Ferguson stood for over 50
years and then we have in 1954 Brown
versus the Board of Education
uh which uh which said the right to a
public education must be made equal to
all unequal terms
and um
then
so that was 1954 brown brown V Board of
Education was 1954.
sort of a slightly more Niche part of
this because that was all about
um segregation more more generally
um
in 1957
uh
writing on writing an opinion on a case
um
I know my notes are weird here Justice
Frankfurter
um
summarized
I mean okay Justice Frankfurter
summarized what he saw as the four
essential freedoms that constitute
academic freedom
this is interesting to me quote it is
the business of a university to provide
that atmosphere which is most conducive
to speculation it experiment and
creation
it is an atmosphere in which they
Prevail quote the four essential
freedoms of a university to determine
for itself on academic grounds who may
teach
what may be taught how it shall be
taught and who may be admitted to study
that's a good list
it's a very good list and it gave me
pause
it made me made me stop and I I want to
continue to spend more time on those
Four Freedoms that Justice Frankfurter
uh declared as the four essential
freedoms of a university again once more
who may teach what may be taught how it
shall be taught and who may be admitted
to study
some number of years later in 1978
um
this is coming I'm I'm getting this
history mostly from the the summary the
of the um of the 2023 decision that just
got handed down and backy I think is how
it's pronounced maybe butchering that
regions of the University of California
versus Alan Bakke decided in 1978
um which was back he was a former Marine
and I think an engineer
who had applied to the UC Davis Medical
School two years running he was a white
guy
and he had not gotten in and some
applicants who were not white who came
in with lower scores and lower gpas I
believe had gotten in and so this got
all the way to the Supreme Court
and it turned out that UC Davis Medical
School had a just an explicit quota 16
out of every 100 applicants
um no 16 out of every seat at 16 out of
every 100 seats were set aside for what
was then called minority students and
that was found in University of
California regions versus Becky uh to
violate the rates violate the rights of
white applicants
policy was struck down and backy was
ordered admitted to UC medical school
that was a deeply fraught
decision that was 1978 there were six
different opinions written by nine
justices there are a lot of opinions
written in this case this week as well
but not not quite
um quite as funny
but Justice Powell's opinion back in
that 1978 case
writing for himself alone
became a touchstone for race conscious
admissions policies
Carol did not find compelling three of
the four claims of benefit from racially
motivated admissions policies but he did
find one compelling he found one of the
four
reasons that the UC Regents had had put
forward as compelling which is that
educational benefits flow from a
racially diverse student body
once again educational benefits flow
from a racially diverse student body
and furthermore he wrote that such an
interest is quote a constitutionally
permissible goal for an institution of
higher education
and furthermore
as
um
as uh Justice Frankfurter had already
said such institutions can make their
own judgments and selection of their
student body
so that is a classic case where
um
a decision is made
for population level it's not yes
um
it is that the population of students
will be better if they are racially
diverse that is to say that they bring
in experience from different backgrounds
yes and actually as uh justice Thomas
writes in his uh concurring opinion
um
which I'll just say like I was I was
blown away by his of the three that I
read in some in some depth and I did not
read I did not read
um any of them completely but
um
his arguments and also his uh just the
the way that he wrote were by far the
sort of the most finely tuned and
um and clear with regard to
um to making to making his points and he
says
I Justice Thomas have been have been
looking for the evidence that this is
true
for all of my career and I don't find it
I feel at this like emotional level like
there is educational benefit to having a
racially diverse uh student body
uh so I don't I'm not I don't think I
agree with him like the emotional level
but he's saying I have been looking for
what the what the purported educational
benefits are and I and I don't find them
now I think what's doing a lot of heavy
lifting there is the word educational
and you know education can mean a lot of
different things but
um let me can I proceed a little bit and
interrupt at any point
um
and so that that Powell's decision in
backy uh versus the Regency University
of California
um is is tricky it's tough It's you know
in lower courts have been trying to
figure out if that's if that if that
establishes a binding precedent
uh that was again 1978 and then in 2003
we have again apologies for
pronunciation so I'm getting this wrong
gritter versus Bollinger
uh who largely agreed with Powell's
opinion that student body diversity is a
compelling State interest
but
identified a few risks of it including
that race
um might not be used only as a plus but
also as a negative
that is used to discriminate against
certain races which of course was
certainly uh the sort of popular
understanding of what was happening at
Harvard with regard to East Asian
students
experiencing lower acceptance rates
um once it you know once Harvard's uh
Harvard was using race as one of the
components of
um of attributes for applicants and
deciding who to accept
and
um
and in part to offset these risks gruder
and there's there's disagreement about
what what they actually what that this
decision in 2003 actually did
um but it said at some point they have
to end
past to end there has to be
a point a standard that you can point to
by which you can say at the point we get
there then it will end and they
estimated in 2003 that 25 years from now
that would be 2028.
um we should really be there by then
they didn't guarantee they didn't
promise they presumably hoped it would
be earlier all of that there wasn't a
you know a hard stop but what they said
was any policy a can't be used as a
negative and B has to has to be finite
in its in its temporal scope basically
um
okay so the first paragraph of this I
don't know why they call it a syllabus
but like the summary of of the document
is Harvard College and the University of
North Carolina are two of the oldest
institutions of Higher Learning in the
United States every year tens of
thousands of students apply to each
School many fewer are admitted both
Harvard and UNC employ a highly
selective admissions process to make
their decisions admission to each school
can depend on a student's grades
recommendation letters or
extracurricular involvement it can also
depend on their race
the question presented is whether the
admission systems used by Harvard
College and UNC are lawful under the
equal protection Clause of the 14th
Amendment
um
furthermore let me find this in this
document and then once I do Zach you can
um show my
this is Robert's majority opinion you
can show my screen here
he writes any exception to the
Constitution's demand for equal
protection again as found in the 14th
Amendment uh yeah must survive a
daunting two-step examination known in
our cases as strict scrutiny
under that standard we ask first whether
the racial classification is used to
further compelling governmental
interests
second if so we ask whether the
government's use of race is quote
narrowly tailored meaning necessary to
achieve that interest
outside the circumstances of these cases
our precedents have identified only two
compelling interests that permit Resort
to race-based government action one is
remediating specific identified
instances of past discrimination that
violated the Constitution or a statute
the second is avoiding imminent and
serious risks to human safety in prisons
such as a race riot
so those are the exceptions that Roberts
with the majority behind him specify as
as the
the compelling interests found in Prior
cases yes and actually the second one is
fascinating hadn't thought of it
but I think what they're saying is if
you have to separate people by race to
keep a race riot from uh breaking out
you can do it yeah you can do it yeah um
yeah yeah yeah exactly
um
so the court has struck down
um has has has basically uh has said no
Harvard and UNC cannot continue to to
use race as a factor in admissions
and that really was based on several
factors including
um that Harvard and unc's admissions
policies failed the two criteria of that
2003 greater decision that I just
mentioned that is greater specified that
race may never be used as a negative
but the first circuit found that
Harvard's consideration of race and
applications resulted in fewer Asian
students being admitted and I will say
just as a side note like
it inherently has to right like if if
you are saying
even in even in the most Bland version
of affirmative action that possibly
exists you are you actually have two
identical students and no that's never
going to be the case and there's only
one thing that differentiates them and
that is race and you you and you
therefore just use that as one little
extra plus and help out the student who
is from an historically underrepresented
uh population you have of course de
facto
um made put made a negative for the
student who's from an historically not
underrepresented population and this
again is a point that Thomas also makes
I had already written my little rant
here and um and Thomas also makes this
point this is you know
it it inherently it inherently does so
therefore how could you have a policy in
place uh where you say well it can be
used for a positive but it can't be used
for a negative like well maybe you're
talking about intent and so you can't
intentionally say we really don't want
any of those people well but but in
terms of math by make by making a choice
is for one group you inherently are
making a choice against another group
I will steal man their argument go for
it I don't I don't believe it great but
the basic point is you can't say Asians
are overrepresented it counts against
you that you're Asian you can identify a
population that's underrepresented and
then it disadvantages the sum total of
all of the other things which are not a
population
as opposed to what was and I did not
look into it but what I understand
um to have been the case
um at least I think at Harvard where in
the sort of the
unquantifiable category of like
personality
um Asian applicants were getting
downgraded yep right
um so that that is that is
that is a little different right does it
doesn't feel an argument yeah
um
and then
these Admissions and then the second
point is these admissions uh these
submissions policies also lack a logical
endpoint
um outright racial balancing has
apparently already been established to
be patently unconstitutional
uh and uh without an end point
you know we we have we have failed to
meet what greeter established in 2003 as
one of the one of the conditions under
which effectively affirmative action uh
would would be acceptable
um
yeah I have a lot a lot more but let's
just let's talk a little bit as I as I
sort of reframe sure yeah
um
the the time point is the main point
that you're like this can't just go on a
definitely point but I don't even think
that's yes the court says that but I
don't the point is it was never intended
to be a permanent remedy right the whole
idea was to correct a past wrong and the
glaring fact of the present is if we
still need it does that not demonstrate
that it doesn't work
right we have had this policy and it has
not effectively erased the problem
therefore not a good policy and yes the
so the problem here is yes the court is
ruling that it's unconstitutional
implying it was always unconstitutional
I guess maybe Robert's first uh
overriding governmental interest to
correct a past wrong is the issue the
one exemption here but the point is if
it happened and to correct a past wrong
but also uh you know the the idea that
there is educational benefit and a
racially diverse student body right that
that that is that is present there is
precedent for that position at the level
of the Supreme Court yep but from my
perspective and I realize you're you're
holding back where you land on all of
this
um so I don't want to I don't want to
steal your thunder but the the concern
those of us who believe
there is a serious historical wrong that
is not a simple matter to undo right yep
I think all reasonable people would have
to agree with that
that it is desirable to undo that right
those of us who believe very strongly in
Merit for example
believe that it is unfair to hobble
somebody at the starting line you know
or to put weights on them and then run a
race right the the magic of a
merit-based system
is most fully realized if people are
well equipped to compete in the
merit-based system to the extent that
they have been artificially hobbled by
past discrimination there is something
to correct but the glaring problem in
the present is
it didn't work
it had massive unintended consequences
this is a classic of uh progressivism
resulting in the creation of a noble
program that becomes uh a becomes
grotesque in the instantiation
and and so therefore
the real question is well if this didn't
work the last thing we want to do is
have it become a loophole in the 14th
amendment that then becomes an addiction
if the point is an addiction yeah it's
good so what we are looking for is a
policy that actually stands a chance of
working and that does not uh cause so
much Carnage both in terms of
disadvantaging people who did nothing
wrong and had nothing to do with past
racism
and the destruction of a merit-based
system which is frankly the goose that
lays the golden eggs right right yes we
should fix it so everybody has access to
the merit-based system and the tools in
which to compete but if you want to
destroy that system in order that it
doesn't embarrass people who've been
historically hobbled then the point is
we don't have anything this is the
system that generates the productivity
that yes is not fairly distributed but
you do not want to destroy that system
in an effort to correct one of its arms
which is that it's not fairly
distributed right and fairly distributed
I do not mean
evenly distributed evenly distributed
would be wildly unfair right you want
people to be rewarded in proportion to
their contribution to the functioning of
that system right that's what you want
that's not an even distribution but it
is a fair distribution and we're looking
for that and we don't have it but this
policy never did it and so the question
is was the court
correct in overturning a policy
were they overturning it because it
hasn't worked
um and if so you know is that Justified
on the basis of the time limit that was
uh set by the prior decision again I
don't I don't read it as a time limit
yeah um they do say in 25 years we think
that this should probably be over but I
don't
and there's a little back and forth
um in between the majority opinion and
the and the Descent but I don't I do not
read it as a time limit uh but but it
but what is clear
um and what the dissent kind of doesn't
want to talk about is uh that there
needs to be an end point that there
needs to be a way to end it there needs
to be something that Outsiders that
anyone can look at and say what will
success look like how will we know when
we've arrived and therefore can stop
this policy right and that is what no
one seems seems to have so let's just um
I'm going to focus for a little bit on
The Descent
um Sotomayor says for instance
passively eliminating race
classifications did not suffice When de
facto segregation persisted
okay
right yep uh I agree with this however
de facto segregation doesn't exist in
higher ed now
right uh and maybe some will
will not disagree
um
we got chased out of a university where
we were tenured College we were tenured
because you were you because I was on
sabbatical because you were arguing
against segregation
yep and it's literally what happened
it's right it's another one of these
things where it had not occurred to me
that uh that's exactly what you were
doing right and uh and you know and what
we were talking about behind the scenes
together
um
the fact of segregation does not exist
in higher now except where the left is
creating it again put that aside you
know or in the other domains that the
so-called left now control like
internalism like it's it's it's not it's
not there it's it's it you know there's
been
there's there's been a push to correct
and we would argue with tools that are
the wrong tools to be using but that has
um that is created
um
different problems often in the opposite
direction from what the original
problems were
so
also to the extent that there are still
inequalities by race due to historical
racism in this country and there are
right
admissions to institutions of higher ed
is not the place to solve the problem
yeah you know you you don't you don't
let people in to Elite institutions who
actually cannot do the work based on the
standards that you have otherwise
uh otherwise created
because by doing so
you will create in them a legitimate
inferiority complex because they really
are actually inferior and you will
create in the non-minority students
a sense that oh people like that
whatever that might mean can't can't
really do the work
and
most egregious of all
you will create in the people from
historically underrepresented groups who
absolutely deserve to be there on their
merits
a sense that they are constantly
battling the reality that other people
look at them and think
you just got here
because of your color
right and you know and
we've had we've had students talk to us
about this right yeah it's it's the
tragedy people who uh
are perfectly prepared to succeed and
are forever dogged by the impression
that they got through based on an
exemption and it's really you know it is
not only is it tragic at the level of
individuals who would survive perfectly
well in a merit-based system yeah but uh
it also
they are the antidote right they are
leading the way this is how it is done
and to the extent that we hobble people
who are succeeding in a merit-based
system by creating the impression that
something else happened
um it is counterproductive to the exact
thing that the policy is nominally built
to to solve exactly
so
you know throw into this mix
um that race is a squidgy word
but you know race is is built on
something
um historical evolutionary but who calls
who what member of what race now is you
know largely up for individuals to
decide
and uh I believe and I don't know if the
work has been done and I would love to
see if it if it has
um that and we've talked about zip codes
before but the ZIP code where you grew
up is more predictive of your life
outcome than is your race at this point
and there's still a lot you know there's
still a lot of overlap between
um between uh ZIP codes that tend that
people don't tend to escape from and end
up living uh fulfilling and rewarding
lives and race in this country there is
still a lot of overlap but socioeconomic
status predicts I believe success more
accurately than does race at this point
in this country right but the problem
the problem with that and
I agree that the zip codes are the way
to see it right and that's that that is
something that you can actually like
that's confined right I mean well the
borders are it's a big difference but
yeah it is it is delineated but but the
point is let's say that you could wave a
magic wand and eliminate a hundred
percent of racism from the system but
change nothing else
the point is zip codes are still
unfairly distributed by race that's the
point is that it requires no racism
whatsoever for a self-perpetuating
pattern to continue including and
especially because we collect the
revenue for schooling by locality right
and so you know that's self-perpetuating
it is not surprising that Beverly Hills
has good public schools and Watts has
bad ones right
um so that system you take away all the
racism and people feel like oh well we
took away racism but the point is you
didn't take away the echo that continues
to haunt new generations and that is
something that demands a remedy but at
the end of the day
this remedy doesn't work and it creates
all sorts of unintended consequences
that are intolerable and you know
unfortunately we're having a
foolish debate in public about this
right you've got teams again right and
it's people who recognize that this is
being used as an excuse that it is
destroying Merit that it is hobbling
people who've done nothing wrong and had
no participation in the racism that is
being remedied right and those people
are just done they have no tolerance for
this policy then you have other people
who you know uh on their best days are
looking at the
um
inequality that remains in the system as
you can see in that example about zip
codes and the point is any remedy is a
good remedy and that's never true right
right no and again this this again is
something that we keep on coming back to
and we've talked about with regard to
covet with regard to so many things like
let's recognize problem a
and someone swoops in and says we have
solution B
and you say ah man problem a is real and
big but your solution isn't the right
one
aha we are told then you don't believe
the problem a is really a problem right
no
we know that covid is bad but we don't
think that your treatments that you're
calling vaccines are the right approach
to dealing with it
no
we know
that this country had a ton of racism in
it and still has repercussions from it
and still has active racism today to
some degree
but these Solutions
don't appear to be working
and therefore don't seem like the right
ones and this you know this this is the
point that you that you made earlier
like like look
we tried it yeah we've tried it and this
so I will I will say now
um
I guess I didn't ever really think that
much about it
um but I was absolutely in favor of
affirmative action 100 percent
and uh
people have asked both of us in the last
few years like what have you changed
your minds about uh really you know
since Evergreen since you know codes all
of these things and
uh this is one of the first things that
occurred to me when I started thinking I
think like yep I
was wrong about affirmative action and
the decision by the Supreme Court on
June 29th of 2023 with regard to uh Race
using race as an element in admissions
at Harvard and UNC in which they said
you can't do that
that was the right decision
I feel I I feel certain that that was
the right decision and
there's one more thing
uh The Descent so the mayor's dissent
um is
frankly unfortunately also whiny and
self-indulgent and I don't see that and
again I didn't read all of the
all of the opinions for the majority
that concurred nor did I read the other
dissenting opinion by by Jackson but um
the both Jackson and Kagan joined this
one so presumably you know sort of you
know signed off on it
well and this isn't particularly
egregious but
well now I'll read it
this is again from Cinema or his
descending opinion at bottom the six
unelected members of today's majority
upend the status quo based on their
policy preferences about what race in
America should be like but is not and
their preferences for a veneer of
colorblindness in a society where race
is always mattered and continues to
matter in fact and in law
what is the word unelected doing there
yeah everything about this is predicated
on previous decisions by the court
also sort of Mayor presumably
understands that she herself is
unelected as well as are the other two
who dissented
so we've got a Supreme Court
no members of which are elected we all
understand that they are deciding issues
of Law and interpretations of the
Constitution
this just seems mean-spirited and
small well it's an allegation of
legislating From the Bench interesting
that it is coming from the batch I get
that right but it's it's so hypocritical
in this case yeah it is and writing that
in like that is now that's that's in the
annals of of you know American history
now like that
aspersion cast yep no it's it's
remarkable and it's it's uh absurd and
tone deaf but uh
I did a little looking into the history
of affirmative action not at the legal
level
I was interested to discover that
actually the term
comes from John F Kennedy oh yeah and
that it was explicitly about reaching a
colorblind state for society and I think
that this is actually in some ways the
important litmus test
will what we have on the left the people
who are uh decrying this this ruling
yeah
is a hyper race conscious view of
the country right right that that is a
positive thing that it is a required
thing this is not the vision this is a
hijacking of affirmative action a failed
policy for a new policy which is hyper
race aware and that in and of itself is
an invalidation right that is not what
the policy was designed for the policy
was designed to temporarily
be used to redress a pass wrong so that
it would be no longer necessary and to
the extent of the policy did not uh make
itself obsolete
that's really all you need to know as as
for whether or not it's a good policy
I did want to say one other thing about
the connection of this that you raise to
our spectacular exit from Evergreen
it is true that
you were on sabbatical my students stood
by me through that episode in which it
was alleged that I was a racist right
led by students who literally never met
me
um there's a reason for that
and it is because I and when you and I
were both teaching you and I were
teaching things that were highly
relevant to questions like this we
specifically did not avoid questions of
race we talked about the fact that
um race is a racist instantiation of a
correct biological phenomenon lineage is
real race is a bastardization used to
disadvantage people right or
traditionally it has been
we talked about why evolutionarily that
would be the case and we talked
significantly about what biology has to
say about the remedy here and what I
think folks on the right frequently get
wrong is that they do not understand how
much of this is uh remediable if one
actually looks at the Deep causation in
other words the populations that have
persistently not done well in our system
are populations that were systematically
disadvantaged that were effectively had
their culture scrambled in order to make
them compliant right and so
understanding that it's not a fun topic
to think about but understanding that
history and why it has taken some groups
and made it difficult for them to
overcome past hobbling
is crucial I don't see how we solved
this without an understanding of that
and you know doing what many on the
right do which is pretending that or
mistakenly concluding that it is some
sort of uh unfortunate but inherent
characteristic right that doesn't help
and um pretending that the only thing
going on is that there are bad people
stealing from good people and that
transfer of wealth is the way to do this
that doesn't work what we need to do is
actually look the problem squarely on
the eye and say you know
populations that have faced uh a
persistent obstacle what is special
about the history there because when you
look you find right it was a disruption
and you know really the only model that
I think will suffice here is one in
which you understand
that culture and genes are equally
biological right because there was a lot
of damage done culturally and
intentionally so
so I believe it's Thomas in his uh
concurring opinion who points out that
and this you know this will be this will
be regarded by those who are decrying
this decision as sort of standard
conservatives talking points but
but really uh Thomas points out uh that
the specific population of students uh
who uh are have been
disincentivized from applying to Harvard
because their rates of acceptance are
going down
are East Asian students I believe and
there's actually a lot of stuff around
too like what even does Asian mean so
you know South Asian East Asian but I I
think it was East Asian I may have that
wrong I would just say Asian
um
but Thomas uh in his in his concurring
opinion says
isn't that a population
that in this country at least part of
them were literally put into camps in
World War II
and
they are the ones being discriminated
against now
not asking for help
um but having
having come through that which was
heinous which was deplorable American
policy yep right and some of the people
who are Downstream of exactly the people
who were incarcerated by the American
government on American soil these were
including you know American citizens
Japanese American citizens
um whose descendants are now having a
hard time getting into Elite
institutions because why because too
many of them take too many of the boxes
that make them look like really good
academic bets
that confuses the story of
past and Justice makes it difficult to
pull yourself up
it just does right
um but again I want to make this clear
we have examples of populations that
have faced real disadvantages that have
succeeded in our system and we have
advantages of populations that
persistently struggle
the distinction in my opinion is based
entirely in whether or not the culture
of those groups survived intact right
systematic disruption of the culture of
Native Americans and African Americans
is the distinction it's not endogenous
capacity and
that is not a fun point to recognize but
it is a point that has a tremendous
amount of Hope built into it because
once you realize that actually there was
a systematic campaign to hobble it took
place at the cultural level and the fact
is yeah you can have come to the U.S you
can have been ghettoized into a
Chinatown or a little Japan or whatever
it was but you kept your culture and
that culture is the bootstraps right so
there's hope there in some ways but it's
also there's also a kind of hopelessness
I think because uh just as
you've said this often you can't create
a myth
you can't write a myth you can't you can
write a story
um that if it's really compelling
May stand the test of time and become a
mess
in general you also can't invent
religion although people seem to be
worse than that
um
but you also can't
really create a culture overnight no so
having having you know emerged from
intact cultures that were scrambled
intentionally in order to
um create enforce compliance
by how like what what then what then is
to be done well I mean this is this is
the answer is that culture I mean it's
I'm not telling you anything you don't
know and haven't written extensively
about but culture is the secret sauce of
humans and the interesting thing about
it right as a biological phenomenon that
is typically handed down vertically it
is transmissible horizontally and that's
why it's special and the point is the
real answer involves
democratizing the culture that we share
As Americans right
why do I think of George Washington as
my forefather
he's not my forefather right but he is
my forefather because he's the
forefather of my culture and it is the
extent to which the culture has been uh
distributed in an unfair way and that
that persists into the present now it's
a very difficult problem to solve now
yeah I mean I feel like there's two
there's two big barriers to this
one of them is most modern American
culture
isn't fantastic that's not what I'm
talking about and the other big barrier
is of course that
it's not actually
the government or the press secretary
that raises the children right it or the
teachers
right they're not that's not their job
and that's not their right it's families
so the you know the cultural stuff
exists at the family level
um you know family families bring in the
culture and teach it to their children
uh
but absent families
you know we may all be swimming in some
kind of a general if you're in America
like cultural American soup uh but
but the the way that you end up with
with the values and the historicity and
the you know the the the habits of both
mind and body are going to happen again
at the individual level largely at home
largely at home except you're dealing
with a I mean look
this is how you get to game B right
because once you realize that this is
not a problem that can be remedied by
minor tweaks to what we've got and then
we don't have to worry about it anymore
you realize you're talking about a total
restructuring but at the moment you're
dealing with
um corporations that study the minds of
young people to figure out how to trick
them into spending money on things that
harm their health and damage their minds
right you can't have a society in which
you get rich by externalizing harm onto
other people right so this is one of a
dozen different places that we could
point to well yes the family is where
you get your values but how difficult is
it to pass on values when somebody just
outside your door or coming in through
your kid's iPad or whatever is trying to
induce them to see the world upside down
so they will spend money in some way so
we have a predatory Society this this is
true but you also need
um
family has to be intact of course of
course but again even that even that
why is it that
um
black families are more likely to be
single parent families
right the answer to that question it
turns out is tied up in a skewed sex
ratio sex ratio that is the result of a
massive level of incarceration of black
males what that does is it hobbles black
females in uh
negotiations between the Sexes that is
to say if black females do not have
black males in large numbers than those
who exist outside of the system of
incarceration are in extra high demand
it's very hard to get them to settle
down so that is not a feature inherent
to a population that is a result of
circumstances now I'm not excusing the
disproportionate level of criminality on
the other hand that in circumstances are
perpetuating themselves because the
young men are growing up in environments
in which it clearly makes more sense by
most by most analyzes uh to sell drugs
on the street than to go to terrible
dangerous schools yeah I mean you know
these are dangerous conversations to
have because you know in order to get
the Nuance right you have to nail every
word but the point is look
nobody chooses a life of crime who has
great Alternatives right you choose a
life of crime because it actually beats
the Alternatives that you do have and so
the structure of the civilization that
creates that predicament that causes
people to engage in crime because it's
their better option that's the thing
that needs to be cured is that is it as
simple as recognizing that of course not
but you know we were just Zach and I our
producer
um we're just talking about this
yesterday in a different domain which
was
sex work
right nobody chooses no no little girl
dreams
about being on the pole
or Worse right or selling her body for
sex
that is a choice that some people end up
making because circumstances have
provided a bunch of choices in which
that appears to be the best one
and in some of their cases it is the
best one
and that's terrible yep that does not
make it an awesome choice
it makes their circumstances terrible
and something that we do have a
responsibility at the societal level to
consider how to address something that
does not involve penalizing those who
are hard-working and skillful and making
a go of it absolutely now the
fundamental at the bottom of all of this
and you know we don't really know this
but
everything that I have seen tells me
that people are uh while far from blank
slates are overwhelmingly similar in
their capacity at Birth
and that
what happens is a wild Distortion of
Developmental environments where some
people have the benefit of really good
developmental environments some people
have bad developmental environments that
teach them a very important lesson that
results in them doing well that's also
Skyrocket right right but
anyway the let's put it this way the
idea that there is something that we
can't really talk about you know
endogenous differences in capacity blah
blah blah blah blah that becomes an
excuse not to address the problem
because it's like well it's genes but
the evidence that it's genes is not
anywhere near as strong as people think
it is because they don't understand the
problems with the term heritability they
don't understand what it really means
and they don't understand how it is that
something can be genetically heritable
and not be a blueprint that's
inescapable lots of genetically
heritable stuff is perfectly remediable
at a non-genetic level and if that
sounds like a paradox to you that's
because you don't understand what
biologists mean when they say heritage
right I swear it's a it's a very broken
term because the common parliament's
implications of it have nothing to do
with the actual biological meaning of it
cool
um
yeah so um maybe maybe
that's it maybe maybe we're there uh
I am
I don't know that I've ever read uh much
of a an opinion that was just handed
down by the Supreme Court before I don't
think I've ever had any reason to
um and
what I have read what I did read of this
actually gave me some hope
the the
the clarity and nuance
in much but not all of what I read uh in
these opinions that is again Roberts
Thomas and suramayor and the summary at
the top
um was remarkable and in education
and uh
that's great that we actually you know
an informed you know no legal background
at all person who is smart can go in and
read these things and go like okay and
all I can find that that decision that
is mentioned go find that and and sort
of cross-reference and go okay yeah I
I agree with the majority opinion yeah
that's that's interesting and
um you know
the Specter of a uh a court that was not
so divided that it was unlikely to
overturn
um past precedent has been uh used as a
as a boogeyman against those of us on
the left for a very long time to prevent
us from thinking independently about
politics
and uh you know at least what you see is
the court being very deliberate about
these decisions which is exactly what it
is supposed to do yeah yep um so anyway
it's an interesting interesting legal
era yeah it is indeed
all right
we are going to take a 15-minute break
and be back with a q a shortly uh we're
also going to be back with another live
stream this Wednesday and then another
one a week from now so we're gonna do
three we're gonna do one Wednesday July
5th that's gonna be and then Saturday
July 8th and then we're gone again for a
little bit and then we'll start our
regular Wednesdays at 11 30 Pacific uh
schedule starting
whatever that day is I don't know
it is in the future sometime later in
July
um
and soon hopefully we're gonna have a
website where we where you can just
check in on that stuff
um but for right now uh we have I guess
it's just gonna be us doing live streams
for a couple uh a couple times now but
then we have you've got you've recorded
a few episodes guest episodes that um
are ready to come out um with you know
really great um great gassy I mentioned
last time okay we got some coming out
that are gonna be good and boy you know
you even mentioned vivec uh ramaswamy uh
that conversation and then RFK you got
two presidential candidates uh in these
recently released Dark Horse episodes so
go go check those out uh if you need
more Dark Horse before we come back to
you next Wednesday and
um you know check out Natural Selections
which is where I write weekly I wrote um
a bit more about the childhood
vaccination schedule this week
we have again that new merchandise at
darkhorsestore.org sign up until proven
otherwise and uh lots of other great
things I was we were lucky to be with
friends
um on Salt Spring Island in Canada this
last weekend and I was carrying around
my epic Tabby tote bag
yeah yes absolutely everything was wild
and by the way happy Canada day happy
Canada Day
um
and uh we have uh you know Hunter
gathers Guide to the 21st century
available everywhere still signed copies
available at darvill's right here uh in
the San Juan Islands we have uh patreons
where you can find us and also locals
which is easy to get to from Rumble
we're going to be moving our stuff from
patreon into locals but there's already
it looks like an interesting Community
happening at locals uh you had one of
your patreon conversations today you're
gonna have another one tomorrow and as
always and tomorrow I'm looking forward
to that one as well yeah Evolution
excellent
um so consider joining joining us there
and um
you can access our Discord server too
through those patreons and soon
um on on locals as well and the Discord
Discord Community is is very Lively
um once again check out our sponsors for
this week which were biome uh maker of
knobs American Hartford gold and Seed uh
with their probiotics
and consider subscribing to rumble
please and liking sharing subscribing
we've got Clips
um everything's on that Rumble Channel
we've also still um on YouTube until we
see you next time which may be 15
minutes from now maybe four days from
now maybe sometime just in the future
still gonna be a dude he's still gonna
be a dude and I want to encourage you to
be good to the ones you love
and then maybe especially if they are
dudes be good to the ones you love eat
good food and get outside be well
[Music]
laughs